like you said no new Wars this makes me
think if uh Donald Trump won the
presidency what the the current
situation in Ukraine would look like but
let me just ask you zoom out and ask you
broadly um do you think the war in
Ukraine could have been avoided and what
do you think it takes to bring it to an
end I think 100% it would have been
avoided not 99% you know president Trump
for uh four years had no problems with
Russia you know we were we were arming
Ukraine but we were working with Russia
and again the first two years we had a
little bit of issue working with Russia
because they were accused of colluding
with us and so we had to go through that
investigation but um but in the second
two years we were trying to focus Russia
on what are the areas where we can
collaborate together I think Russia you
know we thought it was in their
strategic advantage to play uh us and
China against each other because of the
way that everything was done before they
were stuck with China but not getting a
lot for it um under Bush they took
Georgia under Obama they took Crimea
under Trump there was no problems and
then under Biden U unfortunately I think
they misplayed a couple of things uh
which I think provoked uh you know
Russia to to go forward um still no
excuse to do what they did I think that
the invasion was a terrible thing and
and should not have occurred um but with
that being said um I think 100% if Trump
was President there would not be a war
in Ukraine today